foreign
foreign
yeah
thanks to the organizers for putting
together this excellent workshop and for
including the paper and the program
um so this uh talk will build upon some
of the ideas that we saw on Monday
morning
um uh in the very first session of the
workshop and it talks about Dynamic
sampling of uh attributes Steven John
talked about the Brownian motion as a
way of modeling correlation
across Alternatives in search or across
actions in cheap talk what I'll do here
is to come back to the attributes
problem think about static learning in
the attributes problem and model
correlation across attributes using
gaussian a large class of calcium
processes and of course the brown New
Motion is is among the most well studied
of that class
so make things precise let me go over
the attributes problem that I have in
mind there's a principle and an agent
who evaluate the project of Uncertain
value
and the value of that project is
determined by a mass of attributes the
realizations of these attributes are
correlated and just to be very precise
the value of the project consists of a
weighted sum of these attribute
realizations
now the principle and the agent
understand the correlation across
attributes but they disagree on the
weights that they put on different
attributes and they will be learning
about some of these attribute
realizations before making a decision
that learning process will be
constrained in two ways so first
um there will be limited opportunities
to learn so the principal and the agent
cannot learn all of the attributes so
they will be confined to just a sample
size and secondly there will be
separation of authorities on who makes
the decision and who samples in
particular in this model the agent is
the one who samples and the principle is
the one who makes that decision
the question that I ask is the basic
question which attributes are optimally
sampled how can we think of the optimal
sample as varying with the correlation
structure across attributes now before I
move forward I want to note here that in
this problem attributes have sort of a
dual function on the one hand attributes
are components that go into the making
of the value of the project so they
they're sort of payoff relevant on the
other hand attributes constrain the way
that you learn about the project so
attributes also serve as signals about
the project
now um the origins of the attribute
problem cannot sort of uh the the
importance of the attribute problem
cannot be uh overstated in the economics
literature it goes back to Lancaster's
uh characteristic based demand Theory
um and and can you arrive as uh sort of
uh multiple criteria decision problems
um for the purpose of this talk I want
you to sort of keep in the back of your
mind that this these two applications so
first we can think of consumers
willingness to pay for a complex product
that is made up of different attributes
there is a large literature in consumer
research that has shown that consumers
do think about correlation across
attributes when they evaluate and make
purchase decisions and in particular
Mason and Beckett have sort of this
language of the perceptual map of uh of
of correlations across pairs of
attributes
um in much of these purchase decisions
the consumers are not deciding uh are
confined in what they can learn about
these products the the their their
learning of attributes is confined by
trial products or nutrition labels which
give information only about certain
attributes of the products so there is
some interplay there between the
information that's provided in the
purchase decisions yes
so in
in for instance of a health authority
that is designing the the content of
these nutrition labels
um you could also think about household
purchase decisions Collective decisions
and sort of sort of the learning and the
purchase decisions being made by
different members of the household so
I'm being a bit sort of Silent on
exactly who is the second player that
brings a second interpretation of the
attributes problem goes back to
applications in in um in in spatial
applications of evaluation of the
effects of a of a program of social
program across different sites we can
think of the effect that the program has
on sites as attributes and attribute
realizations respectively uh pilot
studies the way through which we often
learn about the effects of different
social programs can be thought of as
this sampling process
um there is um and coming back to the
question of who is the agent and who is
the principal we can think of the
principle as the government that decides
whether to scale up these programs and
the agent as either ngos or or federal
agencies that decide where to place
these Pilots which cites to to try as
Pilots before making this
so what do what does this paper really
do well it does mostly two things first
it offers a general framework of
thinking about attribute correlation now
the picture that I want you to keep in
mind is the following so uh I want you
to think about attributes on the x-axis
and realizations on the y-axis
attribute realizations are correlated
and we can model flexibly that
correlation by thinking of families of
mappings from attributes to realizations
I'll put some structure and discipline
the family of mappings that we look at
and in particular the attribute mappings
will be coming from a class of gaussian
sample paths the Primitive in this class
will be a similarity measure measure
over different pairs of attributes and I
will be talking quite a bit about the
key property that leads to local
extrapolation of first attributes that I
that I refer to as a near statute
property
and then once we understand this
framework then I'll take this framework
to attribute correlation structure uh
and how that informed strategic sampling
so I'll start addressing the question of
persuasion
um
in today's talk in in the paper I I
address a number of sort of features of
optimal sampling the possibility of
inference reversals the value of
sampling your element attributes whether
you want to sample common attributes or
idiosyncratic attributes
um I'll say a few things about them but
mostly I'll be focusing on the value of
sampling your element to use
if there are any questions before I go
to the framework
okay so two players uh principal and an
agent evaluate the multiple a
multi-atribute project of unknown value
and as I said the agent is sampling the
principle is making the decision there's
an attribute space I'll um I'll use the
notation F of a to denote the
realization of attribute a
the value for the project is the sum of
all attribute realizations weighted by a
weight function that's given by Omega
and Omega here is indexed by I because I
want to keep track of the player that
different players have different weight
functions
um we'll put some regularity conditions
this way they're not important for today
you might want to think of either the
attribute matters or it doesn't so
weight either zero or one
the principle is making a decision that
our parameterize through this utility
function so
um this is just a photographic loss over
the uh distance between the decision and
the value of the of the of the project
so the principle and the agent want this
decision to be as close to their
estimate of the value of the project
okay so prior to the principle deciding
on the decision uh the agent is
constrained to sample at most uh cha
attributes at zero cost
if a is sampled then the trialization is
observed perfectly and I'll keep
um the the two players symmetrically
informed throughout the game
some more language so an attribute is
desirable for player I if the weight is
strictly positive undesirable otherwise
um if the weight is zero I'll say that
the attribute is a real Irrelevant for
that player otherwise the uh otherwise
the the attribute is relevant
of particular interest especially to
this talk
um is this structure of of intervals of
attributes that are relevant so
um I'll be thinking of uh
intervals of attributes that are
relevant for the principle and the agent
the overlap of the two are common
attributes and the rest of the
attributes in these intervals will be
idiosyncratic attributes
I'll come back to this later in the
topic yes
these copies are a is an internal
in the general model we might want to
think of it as
not necessarily even in finance
uh so I'm getting to that
yes they will become a knowledge
so um coming back to the question about
documents right so the attribute space
within Rd for today I'll think of just
single dimensional uh attribute space
and in particular
um we will we'll talk more about
interval supports of these weight
functions uh now let me tell you about
the correlation structure so attribute
realizations are determined by an
unknown mapping that Maps attributes to
realizations
and this mapping is drawn from the space
of sample Paths of a known gaussian
process the gaussian process is pinned
down by a mean function and the
covariance function the mean function
takes attributes to the expected
realization the covariance function
takes any two attributes to R okay so it
gives us so basically this is the
mathematical
analog of what I just said
um I'll assume that the pair mu and
sigma are known to both the principle
and the agent and if of course because
we're within the class of gaussian
processes here they fully describe the
prior uncertainty about the project
we can think or we can map Sigma into a
similarity metric across pairs of
attributes I won't talk much about that
today but it's in the paper
this class is rather flexible the class
that I'm considering I will put
continuity of sample facts because
arguably want to think of attributes
that are close in the attribute space
have almost the same realization so I'll
just impose that almost any realization
of app is for views
and it's without loss in this
environment to normalize the variance of
any attributes to be either zero or one
and to load all the rest into the
covariances
so let's come back to the Brownian here
so the Brownian motion is perhaps the
most well known of gaussian processes so
let's map the elements that I told you
about so we've got attributes in zero
one in the x-axis and realizations on
the y-axis
um the Brownian motion is parameterized
by a linear drift so the expected
realization of each attribute is a over
2 in this example and the covariance is
the minimum between two attributes yes
[Applause]
so the uh in terms of the weight
function as a measurement
but I thought the weight was a function
of
voice
and of course the probabilistic sense
there's a measurements
how
much
okay so let's come back to the brown
unit perhaps illustrate to Progressive
so here I can think of the weights all
attributes in zero one you've waited by
weight one so that's a measure sure and
I'll come back to to this picture when I
talk about the value of the project so I
should just pick up the measure on ASB
units but you can but I'll come back to
to weights and to introduce concept
between this right
but for for now you can I think when you
said sample a you might pick a button
sample f okay so coming back to the
center
when you pick a sample
so uh when
um so any sample of attributes gives us
the realizations of these attributes in
the mapping f so the um so coming back
to to the question about what is a
sample here what does it mean to sample
it means that we observe this Vector of
of f of realizations of attributes and
of course the jointly gaussian with some
mean and some covariance Matrix that's
determine by our Primitives
without loss to restrict attention to
non-redundant samples this covariance is
non-singular
now the prior value from the project yes
yes and across all
sample from the project is determined by
the um by the prior mean mu
uh the prior distribution of the values
of course gaussian with this prior value
Nu 0 for player I and a notion of
aggregate uncertainty that of course
depends on stigma
so you can think of this as the
aggregate uncertainty about the project
for player I
start to school in the absence of any
information the principle just takes a
decision that's equal to their prior
value and this is the loss that's
important
okay so coming back to the brand new in
motion the prior values of Weights are
equal to one for all attributes
um the uh the player in this in this
figure wants to estimate the area under
these sample path that's been realized
but of course under the prior which is
the linear drift they estimate the
yellow area based on the red area so the
the triangle
determined by the primary
so let me say a couple of words here on
the on the literature and in particular
I want to emphasize
um this this line of work that in
economics is using gaussian processes to
model correlational growth attributes
and Steve has done much of the work in
this in the spine of work in um finding
and identifying and showing the power of
the Brownian motion across different
applications
um more recently there is work that is
sort of starting to look at different
bouncing processes as sort of
alternative ways that might fit
um different applications and so we're
starting to to open the box of different
gaussian processes as well
um because of the crowd that I'm uh sort
of uh that I'm in front of I want to
mention the the line of work that starts
with spatial statistics and lately has
been taken up by Machine learning that
looks at gaussian processes very much in
the same way that I'm using them here
um and then several of the tools that
I'm leveraging here are coming from work
for instance by erasmussen and Williams
they have a very nice nice textbook on
on Thousand processes
um
in the attribute problem I want to argue
the flexibility of the correlation
structure is key because I want you to
think of the correlation across
attributes as capturing something
intrinsic about the nature of the
project that you're evaluating so I
would argue that in the attribute
problem it's particularly important to
think about a large class of correlation
structures
okay so if there are no questions then I
want to go to the basics extrapolation
and identify a particular property
across this large class of correlation
sectors
so the principle so both of them know
the weights of each other as always
theirs they also know mu and sigma so
there's common nouns you know
okay so give it a sample and the
realization is observed by that sample
players will extrapolate extrapolate to
the rest of the attributes space and I'm
showing here four different
gaussian processes and how extrapolation
goes for those so in particular let's
look at the Brownian here
in uh
in figure a so the the bronium is just
linear extapulation across the data
points that we've observed
um and typically we refer to the the
extrapolation across any two known
points as the Brownian Bridge
now very much in that same way we can
extrapolate the process another process
the orange back process which I'll be
talking quite a bit about and I'll show
that extrapolation is simple for that
process in a in a well-defined sense or
we can go to fancier processes like the
squared exponential which I'll also talk
about or the polynomial which I won't
talk much about but I sort of still want
to show the richness of extrapolation
now
let's use this looks this is actually
just thousand updating
um so from
uh once I look at the the attribute
realizations that I've observed I
extrapolate to the rest of the attribute
space I have an estimate for f of a hat
for any other apat and then I aggregate
all of that into an estimate for the
value of the project so given a sample
and the realizations the posterior
expected value is just a linear
combinations of the simple realizations
what is key here is understanding the
weights that I put on these realizations
um so I'm extrapolating outside of the
sample so I put a weight if I'm
extrapolating to activate apat I weigh
the different sample attributes in a
particular way and then the way that I
put on the JS attribute in the sample or
rather the way that player I puts on the
Jade attribute in the sample Aggregates
the weights that they would put when
extrapolating to each individual
attribute outside of the sample
um there is a standard thousand updating
gives us these weights uh what I want to
point out here is that
um understanding the nature of these
tiles is essential and that is
determined by the covariance sigma and
in principle we can observe so I'll
point out two different Notions of
inference reversal in this environment
the first one is just the idea that you
can have a sample weight that has a
different sign from the sign that you
put on the attribute weight so Omega and
town need not have the same weight so
you can have desirable attributes that
get a negative sample weight in the
sample
now
um
let's consider the following property on
on on these process processes so um let
me think about processes in which only
the closest attribute that I've observed
um is useful for extrapolating to a
given attribute outside of the sample so
in particular in the in the depiction up
here so I can think of this entire space
of attributes but
um to the left of A1 only the
realization of a one is a is relevant
between any two attributes for any
attribute between A1 and A2 only the
realizations of a A1 and a2rl works and
so on I refer to this as the nearest
attribute property this captures in a
sense out of sample extrapolation that
is local
okay or another way to say this is that
the sample will divide the attribute
space into components or clusters of
attributes that are conditionally
independent uh when conditioning on
these values
um captures the notion of sort of the
project can be broken down into
conditionally independent components now
what types of processes will give me
this pattern of extrapolation
um we'll say that extrapolation to out
of sample attribute satisfies the
nearest attribute property if and only
if the attribute mapping X is Markov
if and all this when translated in the
language of the covariance function uh
the covariance satisfies this property
and I want to remind you here that I've
normalized the covariance the variance
of each attribute to either to be either
zero or one without false okay so what
this tells you is that when you wanna
you you look at three attributes
um ordered in this attribute space the
correlation between attribute a and a
double time is just the correlation
between attribute A and A Time Times the
correlation between attribute a prime
and a double Prime
so
um once we take this into account then
we can show that the sample weights tape
a very simple form
um for instance the sample weight of the
first attribute here Aggregates the
correlation of that attribute with with
any other attribute to the left of A1
because A1 is the only attribute that's
relevant for those attributes to the
left we take Sigma to be the entire uh
the entire correlation here whereas for
attributes between A1 and A2
both attributes A1 and A2 are relevant
so we prolate the correlation between
that attribute and A1 by how close that
attribute is to A1
so there is a very simple structure that
gives these sample weights
um now I want to explore the
implications of this property for how
strategic sampling looks like
um and in order to do that I picked two
sort of as illustrative examples two
types of
um of covariances one of which violates
the neurostatinum property and the other
one which satisfies the nearest
attribute property and I will work with
covariances that have a very simple
interpretation a distance based
interpretation attributes that are
closer in the space are more strongly
correlated
now the original back covariance which
is given by this first exponential form
here satisfies the nearest attribute
property because the original Olympic
process is smartphone
the squared exponential covariance which
is also an exponential uh takes an
exponential form that's slightly
different from the orange and million
back one in fact violates the nearest
attributes property it's a non-markov
process
both of these covarians have very
similar forms yet we'll see that the
implications for strategic sampling are
rather different
um
covariances that look like this go back
have been explored in the literature
both in those psychology psychology
literature uh but also in economics
we've axiomatized exponential decay as a
similarity function so that's to say
these these types of correlation
structures are somewhat familiar to us
the covariance kernel is run too
Escape
okay so first let's start from um The
Benchmark in which both the principal
and the agent have the same weight
function so essentially there is a
single player
um from what Annie told us on Monday we
know that this is a relatively simple
problem for gaussian for gaussian
structures so we can rank samples of
attributes in terms of the the
informativeness that they the the
variance of the distributions that they
induce on posterior values and we want
to maximize that informative so we want
to pick samples that have the highest
posterior variance in this environment
uh we can go one step further we can
actually because sample weights are so
important to this argument we can write
the posterior barriers in terms of uh
these sample weights so uh the the
optimal sample in this in this Benchmark
which I refer to as the single player
sample maximizes the sum of products of
this form where the first Tau here is
the sample weight that we assign to the
Jade attribute in the sample and the
second tau is the sample weight that you
decide to that attribute if that was the
only attribute that we observed
okay so this is the characterization of
the optimal sample uh in this in this
Benchmark the second form of inference
reversal that we can see here is that
the optimal sample can feature
attributes that if they were the only
attribute that we observed we'll design
let's say a positive weight but when we
put them in the context of the sample we
assign them a negative weight the reason
why we tolerate such attributes in the
optimal sample is for the value that
they generate the spillovers that they
generate for other attributes in the
sample due to correlation
in the interest of time let me just say
here that the nearest attributes once we
impose the nearest attribute property on
this characterization
we can actually observe that the
optimization problem for identifying the
single player sample boils down to K
local optimization problems what does
that mean that means that if you tell me
um A2 the second attribute in the in the
in the in the sample then I only need to
know A2 in order to pick the the optimal
A1 uh when I look at A2 and A4 that
those are the only attributes that I
need in order to optimize on A3 and so
on
so we can we can uh break this down into
K simple optimization problems
now the argument that I'll make for the
rest of the time here is that
um the nearest attribute property
um limits the value of sampling
irrelevant attributes
in The Benchmark in which the principal
and the agent do not disagree on on some
on on the weights this will take the
following form
the um any single player sample will
consist of relevant attributes only so
if there is no conflict between the
principle and the agent they will never
sample irrelevant attributes
so this is not
um due to correlation between attributes
it's not necessarily the case that you
it's it's not a trivial statement to say
that you never want to sample your
element attributes remember that
irrelevant attributes are attributes for
which you assign
um zero weight however knowing an
attribute tells you things about other
attributes so conceivably we can think
of structures in which it might be
optimal to sample your album attributes
for the informationals below
um however when the covarian structure
satisfies the nearest attribute property
it's strictly beneficial to sample
relevant attributes and I invite you
here just sort of I'll make a heuristic
argument for for why
um this is the case so uh let's suppose
that we've got two intervals of relevant
attributes and I want to think about the
value of sampling attributes outside of
these two red intervals okay
um first let's think about sampling
attributes to the left here so attribute
A1
okay so shifting A1 closer to the
support of the weight functions
um improves posterior variance because
it gives you more information about both
intervals that are element of you
now there's an argument to be made here
because the weight that you put on that
first attribute
um and the weight that you put that you
put on that both in the context of it
being in the sample and if that were the
only attribute That You observe will
increase whereas the weight of the
second attribute will decrease so you
still have to show that the the the
different directions boil down to to
posterior variance going up but the
intuition is that moving closer to both
intervals will increase the
informativeness of the sample
now about perhaps a more intriguing case
in which
um you simply one attribute that's
between the two intervals so in
principle that attribute will give you
information about both intervals of
Interest
um
now if we had two such attributes then
you can see that uh moving a 3 to the
left and moving A4 to the left will
strictly improve informativeness and the
reason is that those two attributes sort
of are each responsible for its own
interval and moving them closer to those
intervals will make the sample more
informative
um if there was only one attribute
between these two intervals then this is
less obvious because moving it closer to
one interval decreases its
informativeness for the other interval
however these two intervals are
independent conditionally on that on
that on the realization of that
attribute and we can show that the
posterior variance is strictly convex in
the in A3 so moving A3 all the way to
one interval or the other depending on
the size of these intervals will be
strictly beneficial
um
takes an argument to show that this is
actually the case for the end points
here in the sample so the first and the
last attribute you never want to put
them in between the two intervals as
well and the argument is slightly more
complex of those two so what I've told
you is that in this single player world
you never want to sample your l1's
attributes
um if the nearest attribute property
holds now can we think of a world in
which you might actually want to do that
that's why we go to the squared
exponential covariance this is the
covariance that is distance based
exponential but violates the nearest
attribute property is not Markov and I
have examples in the paper that sort of
show that
um
even we we with in simple cases such as
when you can sample only one attribute
you might want to place that attribute
in between these two intervals because
that attribute will be informative about
these two both of these intervals and
conditional the realization of the data
attribute these two intervals are not
conditionally independent so we don't
have the strict complexity there
um
interestingly that will be the case if
correlation is high and the the
intervals are of comparable size same as
says if they're comparable size you're
very interested to learn about both of
them so there is high value in sampling
an attribute that will tell you
something about both of them and that
will be most valuable when the
correlation between attributes is high
so you can actually effectively
extrapolate even if you're not in either
of these intervals
okay so I've told you about the single
player problem now let's go to the
Strategic problem okay so this is the
problem in which the agent and the
principal are not uh aligned in their
attribute weights so what's the
inference problem here so we go from a
sample
to the principle making a decision the
optimal decision of the principle is
just um taking a decision equal to their
posterior value
um and so this is what the agent
considers in their expected payoff so
we're looking at the expected value the
expected quadratic loss between the
agent's value and the decisions taken by
the principal
interestingly this expected loss can be
written in terms of two sufficient
statistics
how informative is the sample for the
principle so how much variance does the
sample induce in the principal's
decision
and how much does the sample
align the value of the agent with with
the principal's decision
so we can boil down the sample Choice
into a bivariate gaussian gaussian
distribution between the agent's value
and the principles decision
the sample Choice controls how much
information you give to the principal
but it also controls how
this value the value of the agent
correlates with the principle's decision
so the statement here the the general
statement is that any optimal sample
will solve
um this maximization problem where Alpha
to let's start with Alpha One so Alpha
One is the posterior variance for the
principle so this is the variance of the
of the principal's decision or what we
before had is the posterior variance in
the in the single player sample and
Alpha 2 is the second sufficient
statistic that captures the covariance
between the agent's value and the
principles decision we can write Alpha 2
in a similar manner to the posterior
variance as a sum of product terms
between different sample weights notice
though that in this case the weight the
sample weight the first sample weight is
the principal sample weight and the
second sample weight is the agent sample
weight so this is a term that's
capturing the covariance between the
agents and the principle
so the agent is essentially balancing
two considerations aligning the
principal's decision with his value so
the the agent prefers higher Alpha too
while also giving as little information
as possible to the principle so keeping
Alpha One Low
and the extent to which the agent can do
both is of course constrained by the
correlation structure across attributes
now in this decision problem the
trade-off between alpha 1 and Alpha 2 is
first of all linear and secondly it's
independent of Prior values so this is a
problem that we can handle in
understanding the the form of the
optimal sample
the optimal sample will consist of
attributes that induce positive
covariance between the principle and the
agent this should be obvious if you pick
a sample that induces negative
covariance you're likely to move the
principle in the opposite direction to
the direction that you want them to move
and secondly it's without loss to
consider samples that um for which both
players put non-zero weights
how much time do I have I think we go
until
yes sorry if my
if no I just want to understand the
Strategic part of it so the agent
chooses the K points yes according to uh
they want to authorize their value but
the decision uh the principle then makes
a decision based on the observations and
the utility of both players is this this
squared is the decision correct yes so
and essentially these two sufficient
statistics are capturing first the
covariance between the agent's value and
the decision of the principle and
secondly the variance of that decision
yes I want to know though here that
because of the structure of the decision
problem the sampling does not depend on
on the evolution of posterior values so
Dynamic learning is very much similar
for this
one yes so that's this follows does it
flow from some generaliza that the
principle needs to make its decision The
Way It Was Written here does it follow
from from generalizade the principal's
decision has to be the way it was
written here it's meant to be that like
the principle just takes face valued
observations
foreign
decisions are continuous and just equal
the estimate of the value for the
principle I'm taking it as an assumption
that it's rather a commitment assumption
that once uh an attribute is sample the
transition is observed by both the
principal and agents cannot help correct
yes that's not the more general setting
where it's not a disclosure model or a
chiptop model like the one
sort of sampling model with commitment
yeah
foreign
the principle here is moving second and
making the optimal delicious decision
based on the sample that was observed we
could think about
sort of the principle coming first and
optimizing over the like ways to
incentivize the sampling of particular
samples
um yeah but there is commitment in what
is shown so once the the attributes are
sampled what are their realizations that
are shots thank you now this
characterization will reduce the K
dimensional sampling problem you have to
pick K attributes into essentially a
two-dimensional one you only need to
worry about these two sufficient
statistics given an attribute
correlation structure the task is to
understand the set of possible pairs of
Alpha One and Alpha 2 that we can induce
and then choose the best one uh from
that set so we want to think here about
the the feasible set of pairs of Alpha
One and Alpha 2. the attribute problem
is such that the correlation across
attributes determines the shape of this
set
um so in order to be able to understand
this the shape of this uh of the optimal
sample we need to to put a little bit
more structure on the correlation
now um in the remaining time I want to
make the argument that even in the
Strategic setting irrelevant attributes
are of limited value
we will see that irrelevant attributes
will be sampled sometimes but they will
be sampled minimally in a very precise
sense
so does the agent strategically sample
your album attributes the statement is
that if Sigma satisfies the nearest
attribute property and the um the the
players have an interval uh support for
the for the weight functions doesn't
need to be a single interval could be
multiple intervals then in any optimal
sample two things are true so first no
attribute is truly Irrelevant for both
players so if we see an attribute that
is sampled it must be relevant for some
player
and there can be at most two attributes
that are your uh irrelevant irrelevant
for some player so that's to say if I
see an attribute that's being sampled
first it must be relevant for one of the
players
and second at most two attributes can be
of one-sided relevance for only one
player
um
how do we see this
well um let's um let's start with uh
I'll do this in three steps so let's
start with thinking about so we've got
the agents interval in red and the
principles interval in green here and
let's think about sampling A1 which is
to the left of the agent's uh interval
in this depiction
um moving A1 closer to the intervals uh
to the interval of the agent will
increase both the informativeness for
the principle because we're moving
closer to the principles interval but
also the covariance between the
principle and the agent because it's the
sort of an attribute that moves on
closer will um align their interests
better
so we need to see um by how much each of
these sufficient statistics is moving in
order to determine the trade-off between
the two now because of the property on
the covariances that I showed you that
is actually a sort of a triangle
property across uh for for Sigma we can
show that both of these sufficient
statistics are actually increasing by
the same factor because the trade-off
between these two sufficient statistics
is linear here that means that moving A1
closer to the intervals of the two
players will increase the added value of
the sample by this Factor as well
and this factor is positive so thank you
might we want to sample something that's
in between the principal and the Agents
uh intervals roughly
um
once I sampled something in between the
two intervals become conditionally
independent
so the the covariance that is induced by
any attribute in between the two
intervals is effectively the same
so conditionally on sampling between the
two intervals I only need to worry about
how much information I'm giving to the
principal but of course in that case I'd
rather take a one and move it all the
way to the agents interval in order to
reduce the amount of information that
I'm giving to the principal so you never
want to sample between the two intervals
and lastly
um might we want uh to sample uh more
than two attributes that are irrele
Irrelevant for some player now first of
all let's notice here that the principle
will never pay attention to more than
one attribute that is relevant for the
agent only and that's because all
subsequent attributes beyond that are do
not add any further information if the
nearest attribute property holds
uh but the agent also does not benefit
from giving the principal uh more than
two attributes that are relevant for the
principle
and the reason is because adding more of
these attributes
um will uh not affect the covariance by
adding more of these attributes you're
not covering you're not making Alpha 2
greater but you are adding strictly more
information for the principle okay so
you never want to sample things like in
this known overlapping case that I have
here when uh the these are Irrelevant
for the agent and these are Irrelevant
for the principle you never want to
sample something like A3 because A3 does
not affect the covariance between the
two players but is strictly informative
for the principle
um
and we we we have to make an argument to
show this in all the possible
configurations of overlapping and
non-overlapping uh intervals now coming
back to the example that I've been
carrying with me to show that once the
nearest attribute property is violated
you might actually see irrelevant
attributes being sampled we go to the
squared exponential uh covariance and we
can show that so this is just an
illustrative example here we have a show
so we've got the agents interval the
principles interval and what I have here
is the optimal attribute that is sampled
as the correlation increases from almost
perfect Independence to almost perfect
correlation and as you can see here we
sample your element attributes both for
low correlation and for high correlation
um
one sort of interesting fact is that um
when
um the attributes are almost independent
the primary concern for the agent is to
maximize alignment between the principal
and the agent and that's the reason why
we see attributes in here between the
two intervals being sampled because they
maximize covariance between the
principle and the agent
when the attributes are almost perfectly
correlated the principle just
extrapolates too much from the sample so
the primary concern is to minimize the
amount of information that we're giving
to the principal and that's the reason
why the optimal sample goes as far as
possible in the attribute in the
attribute space
okay so I think I'm
thank you so I'll just conclude by
pointing out a few things that are in
the paper that I didn't get to talk
about so in the paper I look at
questions like might you want to sample
idiosyncratic attributes or common
attributes I've told you something about
uh idiosyncratic attributes but
essentially we always sample s
studiosyncratic attributes as possible
and we maximize sampling of common
attributes in the paper for
um I sort of give a general
characterization of sampling both in the
single player Benchmark and is the
Strategic Benchmark for any k for the
orange and 11 process and we can use the
orange aluminum back and the squared
exponential process to think about
comparative Statics in correlation
because both of these covariances have a
parameter the parameter L that
parametrizes how correlated attributes
are across a given distance
um
there is some
literature very interesting literature
in consumer research that thinks about
inferences that consumers draw uh across
attributes of a product
um so I have a discussion there uh on on
how different universals and the the
sampling of your element attributes
might be uh might have implications for
for such experiments uh on product
evaluation and finally I just want to
point out that the framework is
tractable to address various
applications if uh both in the
attributes problem but also beyond the
attributes problems and problems of
search and uh and and others so
hopefully we'll see more work on on
these alternative correlation structures
thank you
foreign
[Music]
but essentially these three properties
are equivalent so for for the purpose of
what I'm doing here it is the second uh
way of writing things at this
particularly important for me but you
know the grounding is also my fault
right so that's another sort of process
that might only think about is the
status time is the nearest
okay so thanks and see you later